and every once in a while there's an
undrafted quarterback who ends up being
a great quarterback like a Tony Romo or
a Kurt Warner but for the most part if
you want a great quarterback you have to
rely on the draft typically hi in the
draft and that's what the Giants have
done in their quest to fund the
replacement eventually or sooner for Eli
Manning daniel Jones taken sixth overall
by the Giants and Chris there has been a
lot of effort night by GM Dave gentlemen
to defend the decision to take Jones
with the sixth overall pick instead of
waiting for the 17th overall pick now
you were all over this last week once
the the words started to get out that
Jones could be one of the top
quarterbacks that was one team that had
him as the best quarterback on the board
and Gil Brandt compared him to Peyton
Manning you saw through it
the Giants were putting this out there
to get people comfortable with the idea
that they were gonna take Daniel Jones
right the problem is by putting it out
there they had to worry about somebody
getting him before they could get him at
17 so they had to take him at number six
Dave gentlemen said in defending the
decision to take Jones at number six I
know for a fact that there were two
teams who would have taken Jones before
17 it wasn't easy for me to pass up Josh
Allen it was very very difficult but I
think that much of Daniel Jones and as
his future as an NFL quarterback that's
what Gettleman said on Saturday and look
I the only way you know for a fact where
the team's gonna do in the draft is if
you've tapped their phones there's no
way to know for a fact what anyone is
gonna do in the draft until their picks
are made then you know factually what
they did no one ever knows what a team
is going to do because it's all cloaked
in secrecy
except when you're the Giants Chris and
you put the word out there for anyone
who's paying attention to realize they
wanted Daniel Jones yeah well they were
trying to start the propaganda wagon
right there to sell it to the fan base I
think that's where you know it all
started you know and again hey you know
yeah you're right I mean you don't know
for a fact two teams were involved I
mean we've already heard mike lists from
denver who is you know all things John
Elway he reported last night that number
one quarterback on the Denver Broncos
board was drew Locke so that's one
they're not going to admit
they're not going to know their jobs no
no no I probably spent all weekend
saying to Drew Locke you were my guy all
along yes you're right so there we don't
know with the truth there either way
you're right exactly right so we don't
know either way it comes down to this
now I'm not mad at the Giants are taking
Daniel Jones at number six if they
believed he was the guy in the future of
their franchise you do it you don't roll
the dice on any of that now the problem
they have gotten to again here is yeah
is daniel Jones worth the number six
pick of the draft no certainly not one
of the most six talented guys in the
2019 NFL Draft but he is quarterback
he's overvalued that way just by being a
quarterback to begin with but they felt
he was the guy they made the move they
went ahead and did it you know again I
think the tone of all this is a lot
different if he did get picked at 17 or
at the top of the second round I think
Giants fans would feel very positive the
big issue is you know even the common
fan can watch highlights and things of
Daniel Jones and go uh it doesn't look
that great and I think that's what
bothers a lot of the fan base more than
anything no this guy's a smart guy he's
an accurate thrower he's big he's a good
athlete they feel like he plays the
quarterback position the right way
that's why he was drafted and I'm gonna
say something I said to start the show
at seven o'clock yeah you know I you
know I've seen worse first-round picks
at a quarterbacks here in just recent
history okay I mean whether you want to
get into Paxton Lynch with the Denver
Broncos Blake bortles at number three
Christian Ponder at number seven or 10
excuse me God who else am I missing
Johnny Manziel at 22 a Tim Tebow in the
first round I'm just telling all Giants
fans to talk them off the ledge right
now this guy is certainly a better pick
than any of those I would say it's
better than Teddy Bridgewater at 32 he
has more talent than those guys right
off the bat now he doesn't have the hype
and maybe some of the sex appeal those
guys had and that's why fans are are a
little down on it but it is bothering me
a little and I guess I feel a little bit
guilty to be a part of this where I was
saying to pick him at number 6 was crazy
but the giant fan base is killing this
kid up
here and I don't necessarily love that
aspect of it this kid still has a chance
to be something and be something good I
don't think he was worth number 6 but
like I said there's positives here and
he does have a lot of franchise
quarterback traits yeah a lot of the
guys you rattled off weren't top-ten
quarterbacks there's something about a
top 10 yes I guess it's a rare draft
pick to have although not so rare for
the Giants in recent years but they're
trying to get out of having top 10 draft
picks and if you're going to take a guy
in the top 10 he had better be a star
player that I'd rather not be rolling of
the dice and that's what it feels like
here and part of the problem is the
Giants are responsible for him not being
available at 17 because they decided to
inject into the mainstream news cycle
the idea that Jones is a guy that they
were locked on to I mean the Raiders
were able to get Cleveland Farrell at
four they were trying to trade down they
were hoping somebody would call nobody
did that that's from Peter Kings
football morning in America because it
was so quiet about Farrell that they
could have gotten him later because
nobody knew they were on to him right
well he wasn't worth the number four
pick but they went with the guy they
liked so that's it's okay but go ahead
sorry but but born it's a quarterback
when it's a quarterback it's different
and when you're the Giants and you've
been in the middle of this vortex of
criticism for how you've handled Eli
Manning you've just got to get it right
and you know here's the bottom line and
this is the truth the truth isn't that
Dave Gettleman knew for a fact there
were two other teams are going to take
him that's baloney the concern was this
it was so out in the open that they
liked Daniel Jones they were running the
risk of someone trading up to 16 to get
him before they could this isn't about a
couple of teams Washington and Denver
who were between six and 17 this is
about some team that was after seventeen
that could have jumped over them at 16
which quite possibly would have happened
because we all knew they were gonna take
Jones at 17 if they didn't take him at 6
and when it's that far out in the open
your only choice is to take him at 6
that's the truth yeah it's not what
Washington or Denver would have done
it's what some other team would have
done to get to number 16 yeah I get that
and you know I still I would severity
even challenge that and go well you know
who who was gonna trade up back that
somebody was
their mouths shut I guess I wanted
Daniel Jones but didn't feel compelled
to tell the world they wanted Daniel
Jones named I said that last week yeah
the Giants love this guy they have to
assume that there's out of 31 other
teams someone may love him as well yeah
well it's all over the place again you
know listen I I know I can name I could
rattle off a few teams that had drew
Locke as their number one quarterback I
can rule I could throw out a few teams
that I know Dwayne Haskins was the
number one quarterback so you know you
never know where everybody is valued on
a certain football team they're coming
for teams that have quarterback yeah
right I know that they ranked them
anyway yeah it means a hell of a lot
less if they're not gonna draft a
quarterback doesn't it well yeah but I
still think that even teams that have
quarterbacks they do their due diligence
on the position no matter what and
they're gonna do there are a lot of time
the offensive coordinator and the GM
because quarterbacks just to position
too too important of a position in the
NFL to not evaluate everybody you don't
know if that guy comes your way maybe
four years after free agency whatever it
may be so there's all of that you know I
think at the base level you know again
the Giants put themselves in this corner
like you've said they did they thought
this was the guy so they just said we're
going all-in this is a guy and we're
gonna get again try to call our media
friends to sell this guy on the New York
area the problem is like I said at a
very base level even the common fan can
look at some of the highlights and go
doesn't look that special and like you
said with the number six pick you want
special that's really the issue in The
Bachelor the backlash here because you
want somebody in the number six pick of
the draft or any top 10 pick should have
something truly elite about this guy and
I think the thing that the Giants think
is elite about this guy is something
that we can't really quantify as fans or
evaluators in the media and they think
his decision-making and his ability to
process information are all the elite
traits of it and yeah you know the
quarterback the arm strength and the
quickness and his feet and those things
yeah are not quite to my liking as far
as a quarterback goes but they're still
very good one of the things that Dave
Gettleman said in the run-up to the
draft is that he wants a guy who can
handle the mental requirements yes
of being the starting quarterback of a
New York franchise and you know what
Daniel Jones gets his first test right
out holy cow coming in in the middle of
this storm and and it's amazing to me
we're gonna talk later in the week I I
assume about the the over/under totals
for rookie quarterbacks there's a new
sports book that's opening in Vegas June
1
they've got Daniel Jones over/under
starts for 2019 at 7 and a half which is
amazing to me because my first thought
is Oh take the under and then you start
thinking oh they're trying to get us to
take the under what do they know that we
don't Chris yeah well yeah they're
trying to get us to take the under you
know I guess the thing they know is this
is the number six pick of the draft we
all know that Eli Manning is towards the
bottom of football of starting
quarterbacks I would say he's actually
even below the the bottom as far as
starting quarterback so I would name
some backups that I think are better
than Eli Manning at this point in his
career and Daniel Jones at the very
least again has has size and when
there's a lane that opens up he can run
his arm is going to be stronger than Eli
Manning's is right now and I think
that's probably what Vegas is looking at
- again there's that factor that we
talked about a little bit with Dwayne
Haskins and the Redskins so any one of
those things again where yeah Eli's won
two Super Bowls but it's the end of his
career
Daniel Jones is gonna get on the field
and look a level better than Eli Manning
physically everyone's gonna go well you
look stronger whoa he's definitely
faster while he's definitely quicker and
even though his arm might not be Dwayne
Haskins or Drew Locker
calimary it's gonna be stronger than Eli
Manning's - we're the team and the
coaches are all gonna see that and go
dim he's making throws Eli can't make an
OTAs right now and I'm guessing that's
part of Vegas is law get logic as well
I'm gonna throw something out here for
future reference just just just put a
pin in this one okay the idea the idea
now because I think Eli Manning if
nothing else is extremely self-aware he
gets it right right right and he sees
where the handwriting is I mean it's
sandblasted on to the wall that Daniel
Jones is the future and he knows how it
was handled for him back in 20 or 2004
rather when Kurt Warner even though they
were above 500 got benched for Eli
Manning after nine games right if
there's an injury to a quarterback to us
Arden quarterback with another team and
I know Eli Manning has a no-trade clause
maybe he would waive it for something
like this because Sal Paolantonio said
late last week that Manning plans to
play beyond 2019 and he surely knows
it's most likely not going to be in New
York even though they're trying to throw
out the Green Bay model now instead of
the KC model I won't be surprised if
there's a starting quarterback that goes
down like Teddy Bridgewater did three
years ago that we don't suddenly hear of
the possibility of Eli Manning taking
over that team because at least he would
go to a place where he knows he's the
guy all year long because in New York I
think that it's safe for him to assume
he may not be the guy all year long I
don't think you're crazy with that you
know again I think you know to your
Teddy Bridgewater point it would have to
be a situation just like Philadelphia
that year where they get through
training camp and they go wow this
daniel Jones guy our first-round pick he
knows the offense and he's pretty good
he's further along than we inspected so
yeah we can move on from Eli Manning but
man I just don't know if the Maris could
actually do that and trade an Eli man be
very interesting to see if you do get
this right I will call you something
cool for a week like oh oh great god
Mike Florio or something that's not very
happening yes I like the title but I
wouldn't say it's cool okay well often I
find I'll find something else that we
can agree on but we got to keep an eye
on and keep an eye on it keep an eye on
it but if it doesn't happen never bring
it up again okay take a break when we
return
we need to bring up one of the biggest
stories in the NFL Draft and all the
Tyreke Hill situation continues to hover
over the Kansas City Chiefs and the NFL
we'll give you the latest and where this
may be heading when PFT life continues
right after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports